our Kelly arrested on federal sex crime charges et has confirmed the 52 year-old R&B singer was arrested in Chicago on Thursday we've reached out to Kelly's rep attorney NYPD Chicago police and homeland security for comment the arrest comes two months after Kelly was charged with an 11 additional counts of sexual abuse in May including aggravated criminal sexual assault and sexual abuse related charges among others in March the singer sat down with Gayle King where he vehemently denied all the claims against him that he had sex with many different accusers some of them under age 80 spoke with Kelly's crisis manager Darrell Johnson exclusively in May miss Kelly isn't a good spirit he's in high spirit and as he's always stated he's innocent he looked forward to a speedy trial and make into court he's not concerned about facing any times he believes that it's a an effort to destroy his career